it's become extraordinarily trendy to
talk about free speech and censorship in
very particular partisan polarized terms
today we're going to look at much of our
coverage of free speech and censorship
in a deep dive on the subject let's get
right into it the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
you might know Jeanine Pirro she's this
former prosecutor former judge who now
is on Fox News this is super interesting
Jeff he sent me his research about this
very recently after this Muhammad
cartoon contest that took place that Pam
Geller set up in Arizona which the there
was a shooting there was it Arizona or
Texas now I'm forgetting I believe it
was Arizona no it was in Garland Texas I
don't know I don't know why I was
thinking Arizona in Garland Texas
Jeanine Pirro decided to comment about
free speech here's what she had to say
about free speech take a listen
you know free speech in America is
non-negotiable
no matter what the perceived
consequences no matter the worry about
retribution from Islamic extremists
period end of the story a primer the
First Amendment wasn't established to
protect speech that everyone agrees with
the whole point is to protect even hate
speech speech that offends speech that
insults even that liberal icon of the
Supreme Court Justice William Brennan
wrote government may not prohibit the
expression of an idea simply because it
finds it offensive or disagreeable the
Supreme Court ruling burning of an
American flag burning of a cross and
cursing dead soldiers at their funerals
by the Westboro Baptists Klan all
disgusting and repulsive to me are
protected by the First Amendment pam
Geller's draw the profit contest in
Garland Texas pales in comparison to
those examples but because of her many
in the politically correct class want to
rethink free speech because of the
sensitivities of some very clear
position right free speech above all
else doesn't matter if it's offensive
doesn't matter if people don't like it
free speech above all else free speech
must never never ever ever be mitigated
except as Jeff II found out what did
Jeanine Pirro say about free speech back
in 2011 and it was in the context of a
Muslim
who was preaching what they considered
to be violence in the United States what
did she say about free speech and the
First Amendment back then let's go to
the video that's with the sort of
political process
ughter agreeing Katie yeah but he said
that he said a newly converted ghetto
Islamist he's been at this since the USS
Cole bombing he's been at this since
September look he was preaching in a in
a in a mosque in in Virginia openly
right should we revisit the First
Amendment giving the violent rhetoric
that this guy was involved in I'm sure
you want to go there but I do I don't
get it Louis does Jeanine Pirro respect
the First Amendment no matter what for
all kinds of speech or does she think
that the First Amendment needs to be
revisited revisiting part of the
Constitution I didn't think that that
was something that was that I thought
that was blasphemy for the so-called
constitutional right which of her to
exactly opposite positions on the First
Amendment is her real position I think
that she is simultaneously holding both
of these positions because one of them
has to do with Muslims want to say who
want to say things that she doesn't want
them to say and the other has to do with
being able to say whatever you want
about Muslims which the Muslims don't
want you ah I see what you're saying so
she has one position on the First
Amendment based on Muslims and then
another position on the First Amendment
based on those who criticize Muslims so
if you consider it that way there's no
contradiction at all it's just the First
Amendment applies differently based on
who you are right it basically doesn't
apply to Muslims and it does apply to
everyone else
that's her position a former judge a
former judge Jeanine Pirro let me remind
you great research by Jeff II thanks for
sending me that on today's bonus show
the first lady questioned if Hillary
Clinton were to become president of the
United States
the Swedes get pretty clever at chasing
away Russian submarines crowd funding a
new nation and Microsoft will no longer
make versions of Windows what will they
do Lewis will tell us I'll tell
about my experiences with windows
freezing within 30 seconds of installing
a brand new version of Windows I'm sure
some of our audience can relate to that
make sure to get the bonus show by going
to david pakman.com slash membership we
depend on funding through the membership
program for this show so if you like
what we're doing if you think sixteen
cents a day maybe is worthwhile for a
show that's produced five times a week
for you david pakman.com slash
membership is the place - I would say
vote with your dollars but it's 16 cents
a day it's almost like vote with your
spare change check it out david
pakman.com slash membership back after
this interesting story going on
involving twitter and right winger Milo
you Napoles who has been a guest on our
program Twitter says that they have
permanently banned Milo yu-na police
from Twitter after they believe he
encouraged his followers to go after
Ghostbusters actress Leslie Jones with
racist and insulting tweets Leslie Jones
happens to be black here is a quote full
screen from Twitter
Twitter spokesperson told BuzzFeed news
people should be able to express diverse
opinions and beliefs on Twitter but no
one deserves to be subjected to targeted
abuse online and our rules prohibit
inciting or engaging in the targeted
abuse or harassment of others so if
you're not familiar with milo he is
super popular among the alt-right he's a
trump supporter he gets invited to speak
at college campuses he gives speeches
that are often as short as going up to
the podium and saying feminism is cancer
and then just going back to his seat and
taking questions the events that the
college is often her protested he's more
or less a provocateur and there are
people including Trump supporters who I
guess because Milo is a trump supporter
who were saying Oh Twitter has banned
Milo his free speech rights have been
violated and of course this is
ridiculous right Twitter is not the
government they have policies which they
believe Milo violated specifically that
he's engaging and inciting the targeted
abuse of specific users there is no
right to having a Twitter account now
you can disagree with Twitter's policy
or you can argue Oh Twitter is on
equally or unfairly applying the policy
to Milo we believe because of his
right-wing beliefs or whatever but what
is with the free speech
misunderstandings Louis it I don't know
what people think this is I mean when a
government writes laws the laws are
enforced by the government and that
means if you violate certain laws you
get tried in a court you're found guilty
you're convicted and the same applies to
people who you know that's how it works
so unless you are tried convicted and
imprisoned or punished somehow by the
government for just expressing your
First Amendment rights then your First
Amendment rights have not been violated
I I get it you get it we all get it here
right yeah and Rachel Milo has responded
by saying this is the end for Twitter
anyone who cares about free speech has
been sent a clear message you are not
welcome on Twitter if you believe that
there that this this is a sort of in
unequal application of Twitter's policy
that's one thing but free speech seems
to be very misunderstood by many of his
defenders it definitely is because it
makes me believe that they don't think
that there's repercussions for what you
say and if something that you're saying
is kind of Yaz loosing violating a law
then it's going to violate a law no
matter what I'm not saying that it is
but I'm saying if it were something that
was hateful or some sort of very kind of
negative speech but it's also
interesting because it kind of reminds
me of how Facebook now is struggling to
define hate speech and the aftermath of
all these shootings and especially with
the live-streaming of that video and I
know you talked about that earlier so I
just think it's kind of within the
framework of hate speech and social
media I don't think the lines are as
blurry as people think they can get away
with well the the argument that his
defenders are making is that the problem
is that his views are conservative right
rather than that they are actually
inciting racism against Leslie Jones and
thus Lewis it is sort of a a political
statement that is being made now
Twitter's defenses we are taking these
incitement some people call it dogpiling
incitements very very seriously
Milo innopolis is not the only person
who in the last 48 hours has been
permanently banned he may be the one
who's getting the most attention this
was on the front page of cnn.com etc but
there is a counter-argument which is
more nuanced which is no it's not a
violation of free speech but this is a
form of censorship and that's where I
think it gets a little blurry err which
is to what extent if if the if even
those incited by Milo are not
threatening violence for example then
maybe there should be a more laser fair
attitude by Twitter on this I don't know
yeah well maybe but Twitter has the
right to censor their users and you
don't have to use Twitter you can you
can use anything you want so I agree
that it is a form of censorship but
still I mean how mad can we really be at
Twitter for that what do you think
Rachel I mean is this just a case of
Twitter is just a private business and
they can do whatever they want and even
if they said we are not going to have
conservatives on that would still be
something they would be able to do there
might be serious repercussions for that
in terms of PR but they would be allowed
to do that I think in terms of the
definition of censoring information I
agree with Luis it is but I do think if
you're violating a policy especially a
policy that is pretty clear they're
there their policies are pretty clear
and how they define hate speech and if
some someone is kind of pointedly
putting that out there and there is a
credible threat then I think okay it
might be censorship but it has it has a
good reason for it the Donald Trump
forums online are abuzz over the banning
of Milo innopolis we will see what new
platform he now uses to guess beerus
bill to get his material out there maybe
tumblr tumblr right here is huge right
now among the alt-right the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com i was actually going to cover
this story earlier in today's show
except then trump's violent rhetoric was
actually linked to a specific shooting
the one in New Zealand but shortly
before the shooting in New Zealand
Donald Trump issued the type of threat
that we hear from authoritarian
dictators about using the police and the
military to crack down against political
opponents which is of course completely
antithetical to everything that the
United States stands for or at least
should stand for this actually wasn't
noticed for a few days Donald Trump gave
an interview to Breitbart it was early
last week in fact and at a certain point
in this interview he said supporters of
his might get tough on people who oppose
him politically this includes the
military this includes the police and
this includes biker gangs now I'm going
to show you
bright Bart's own transcript of what
Trump said this isn't a summary this
isn't some left-wing website rephrasing
what Donald Trump said this is bright
Bart's transcript of what Donald Trump
said they conducted the interview Donald
Trump said quote it's so terrible what's
happening you know the left plays a
tougher game it's very funny I actually
think that the people on the right are
tougher but they don't play it tougher
okay so far it's unintelligible by the
way Trump goes on I can tell you I have
the support of the police the support of
the military the support of the bikers
for Trump I have the tough people and
they don't play it tough until they go
to a certain point and then it would be
very bad very bad but the left plays it
cuter and tougher so let's put aside for
a second the New Zealand shooting that
took place over the weekend even without
that we now have exactly the type of
comment that
can add to Trump's subtle and sometimes
not so subtle fomenting of political
violence remember that in the United
States political violence exists almost
exclusively by the right okay this is
Trump sort of foreshadowing physical
confrontations I guess based on what
he's saying
between left-wing protesters who are
almost exclusively nonviolent and Donald
Trump's biker gangs as well as the
military and the police now you might
say hold on David
Trump says police and military but he
doesn't mean that the police and
military are going to enforce Trump's
political views with violence they are
simply for law and order if the left
becomes violent in their opposition to
Donald Trump income the military and the
police and they will simply enforce the
law wrong okay that's a ridiculous
defense police have a job to enforce the
law period the fact that they support
Trump politically which Trump is
bringing up should have no place or
importance in the fact that if people
break the law
the police will step in now as far as
even mentioning the military the
military is not supposed to be used for
domestic law enforcement period there's
something from 1878 called the Posse
Comitatus Act commetators not exactly
sure how it's pronounced which limits
the use of the federal government to use
the military for domestic policy
enforcement or domestic law enforcement
when Trump mentions even the possibility
of using the military in this way it's
outrageous and once again once you talk
about as Trump says the military is on
his side you're wading into very
dangerous and possibly illegal territory
and I was thinking Pat if you look at
who uses the military to enforce their
political positions it's not good
company it's exactly the authoritarian
types that were concerned Trump is so
impressed and enamored with yeah this
absolutely sounds to me like a veiled
threat it's kind of like Trump saying I
could beat you up if I wanted to but I'm
going to show her
I'm not going to I certainly hope it
never comes to this I hope we never see
the police and the military and the
biker gangs fighting against the people
but if there is ever time that it gets
to that it maybe if Trump loses the
election and wants to fight back in some
way doesn't want to go down and I hope
it never gets to that but I think we're
gonna talk about that a little later in
the show yeah we are and we've talked
about that before and we will talk about
it again and and just to put finalize so
we've got the police and the military
then the biker gangs that we're now kind
of getting into the realm of the absurd
but Vladimir Putin has actually used a
Russian nationalist biker gang called
the night wolves who are funded in part
by the Kremlin to do all sorts of
political stuff in Russia it's really
vile it probably impresses Donald Trump
and once again these comments i won't
react a stik terrorism is but these are
the types of comments that would fall
under the umbrella of stochastic
terrorism publicly demonizing or
threatening a person or group which
statistically makes it likely that
someone will go and act out what it is
that is being suggested in this case
political violence by biker gangs the
police and military against the
political opponents of Donald Trump
Donald Trump Strunk that's an
interesting one very dangerous stuff and
I want to hear from you about it what is
your reaction in terms of Trump's
rhetoric to the New Zealand shooting
what is your reaction to Donald Trump's
thinly veiled threats to use the police
and the military and biker gangs to
crack down on political opponents by the
way political opponents that Trump
hasn't even said are violent I mean we
know that most of trumps political
opponents aren't violent the political
violence is coming from the right trumps
not even saying that this would be in
response to violence he's saying this
would be against his political opponents
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show follow
me let me know what you think and we'll
follow up on it later in the week okay
as many of you know we have a discussion
forum that exists on Reddit for the
David Pakman show we have nearly 7,000
viewers and listeners participating
there you can find it at david
pakman.com
reddit that's re d di t I want to go
through some interesting posts and
discussions from the subreddit including
is the alex jones issue about free
speech or antitrust i find this very
interesting because i brought this up
when we were talking about the alex
jones controversy the free speech issue
is not actually an issue when it comes
to the government's limitation of free
speech it's not a First Amendment issue
we can talk colloquially about whether
YouTube is de facto or or in practice
censoring by saying we don't have to
take Alex Jones channel but the argument
for me that is a stronger one than a
free if you're going to make it a
free-spirit issue you have to talk about
the antitrust issue because how do you
make this a free speech speech issue if
you can successfully argue and there's
legal precedent up for this I think it's
a 1966 Supreme Court case which says
certain entities if they get so big and
contains such market share that they
become sort of indistinguishable bita
from an official government entity or
actor all of a sudden government that
they have to be or can be regulated as
if they were governmental institutions
now whether it would apply to speech if
your YouTube and you're determined to be
that big it would have to all be
legislated but the point is if you're
really arguing that the problem is
because of YouTube size it becomes a
free speech issue isn't it really an
issue about having a system where
companies can get this big in the first
place yeah that's a fair case to make
but certainly I think libertarians and
folks on the right in general wouldn't
be the ones to make it in most cases
like they're not the ones to argue
against you know or to argue for
antitrust laws no their but it's it
would help them in this case that's for
sure yeah and I think that this is
something that we we really should be
talking more about because it's part
part of all this is that Spotify iTunes
etc the reason we need to think about
them differently it's not just a small
business saying listen we don't have to
do business with everybody as long as
we're not buying
violating non-discrimination laws their
case is that these are so big that it's
different well maybe we should look at
how they got so big in the first place
and you're right Pat a lot of them don't
want to do that
also from the david pakman show
subreddit what people mean when they say
free market healthcare and this is a
great post that was put together by one
of our editors who lists all of the ways
in which we already don't have free
market healthcare right people like to
say the system we have is a free-market
system where health insurance companies
can offer plans if those plans are good
enough at the price they are charging
they will get customers and otherwise
the company will naturally go out of
business or they will have to either
improve the coverage or reduce the price
the problem is as this poster points out
we subsidize and tweak the free-market
status of health care all the time
everything from public education for
those who become doctors public funding
of colleges to create doctors in the
first place
subsidizing the costs of new hospitals
for for-profit health care and hospital
companies it's a very long list and of
course it's a very good point which is
that we like to talk about or some like
to talk about this industry as a free
market that industry is a free market
and very often it ignores all the ways
in which it's not actually a free market
but we seem to be okay with those in
principle or at least we don't see
anybody arguing to change those and with
a lot of these provisions you know tax
deductions for medical research which
lets the government pay for all private
medical research that's a modification
to the free market it's not a totally
free market and to argue that what we
should have is a free market healthcare
system would require getting rid of all
of this stuff that we already have and
there's not much appetite that I see to
do that from the left or the right
also from the david pakman show
subreddit this is kind of funny well
we've been putting up on social media on
Instagram on Twitter producer max has
been finding nuggets of wisdom from the
show and converting them to text form
and posting them online as quotes of
mine and unfortunately that has now been
perverted or subjugated because someone
took one
those quote graphics and put what I
think is a quote from Donald Trump the
quote that's being attributed to me is
yeah that's her with the gold I better
use some tic-tacs just in case I start
kissing her you know
I'm automatically attracted to beautiful
I just start kissing them it's like a
magnet just kiss I don't even wait and
when you're a star they let you do it
you can do anything grab them by the
[ __ ] you can do anything that is not
something I ever said on this program or
anywhere this is a quote from Donald
Trump but it's now being spread around
the internet it's something that I had
said I've said and I am here to tell you
today it's just not something I've ever
said I think it sounds pretty
presidential I would have to worried
about it if I were you I I could get
mice if it weren't for the fact that I
wasn't born in the United States I feel
like this is a quote that could get me
elected president it's not gonna hold
you back you could still go on to
achieve great things it certainly won't
limit me I joined the discussion it's
not all fake quotes of me there's
actually really good discussions that
happen on the subreddit you can find it
at david pakman.com /re d di t let's go
back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
caller from 9 1 9 hello who's there
what's on your mind today North Carolina
great David I just hey David glad I get
to talk to you I found your your show
online and boy I love I love every time
you go down there thank you I just
walked in the door and I saw I read a
headline that Trump wants to cancel NBC
and and all those other is is that is it
just getting more insane or is that a
real it's not a real article yeah it's a
real article sadly and so we've been
basically seeing a three pronged
approach a three pronged attack on media
from Donald Trump number one has been
during the campaign talking about
opening up libel lawsuits just making it
easier to sue media outlets and that's
really dangerous you know we don't want
to restrict media's ability to do
critical and investigative reporting and
we already have laws against libel so
then number two is along net neutrality
lines net neutrality the attempts to
rollback net neutrality to from a
technological standpoint just make it
more difficult for media to operate into
make it make it worse for independent
media which would be separate from NBC
and then laughter he has been Donald
Trump's assertions and these have
happened on social media on Twitter this
idea that he decides what's real news
and what's fake news that he decides who
should be shut down and who shouldn't be
shut down from the point of view of sort
of government regulation which is funny
because supposedly Trump is part of the
party of the free markets and of letting
the free market dictate what's around
and what isn't around and so it's it's
been a dangerous attack and yes
unfortunately David that's a real
article that Trump is talking about the
possibility of or wanting to see certain
media outlets shut down and we should
all be very scared no matter your
political orientation yeah I agree with
you a hundred percent I'm gonna stop
reading the news for a couple days I'm
not depressed yeah but it's nice talking
to you David keep up the good work
all right thank you likewise always
great to hear from other callers named
David the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm joined today by Burt newborn who is
professor of civil liberties at NYU Law
School former legal director of the ACLU
and also author of the book
Madison's music on reading the First
Amendment the First Amendment is if
you're at all discussing politics in
2015 so relevant and you've been looking
very closely at what the First Amendment
actually says it's not clear that
everybody is doing that recently so
let's start there what does the First
Amendment say what doesn't it say also
well in fact the First Amendment is
consists of 45 words nobody ever and
including the current supreme court ever
tries to read all 45 words at once what
they do is they pluck a couple of words
out of the text like the free speech
clause which is a 10 words or the press
clause or the petition Clause or the
Establishment Clause and they read them
as though they were self contained
documents and they hold a couple of
words in their hands and they think that
they're getting the full meaning of the
text I'm urging people to remember that
the text is 45 words it's not just a
couple of words long and you would never
read a poem by tearing a couple of words
out and thinking we're getting the poem
you would never listen to a great piece
of music by listening to a couple of
notes and thinking we're getting the
whole piece of music and I think we've
made a terrible mistake by cannibalizing
the First Amendment into a kind of
several different pieces of turf that
don't seem to have any connection with
the rest and I urge people to read the
whole amendment and if you read the
whole amendment there's a remarkable
story there and tell us about now that
you have put so much time into looking
at those forty five words and looking
looking at the history of those
forty-five words how should the app for
the lay
person what's the accurate understanding
of the First Amendment yeah the
important thing in my book I mean to the
extent the book has anything important
at all
it's that lay people can read the First
Amendment just as well as judges there's
no magic in that text there's no special
license that lawyers have to know what
the true meaning of the First Amendment
is the words are there for us all to
read and the important thing to remember
is that the First Amendment is made up
of six ideas it's the only time in our
cultural history that those six ideas
have ever been listed in a single
document when Madison was working on the
First Amendment he had 42
documents that he was looking at 42
source documents that he was looking at
ranging from the Magna Carta way back in
1215 through the English Bills of Rights
through the colonial charters through
the Revolutionary Bills of Rights um
none of them had anything like this
remarkable organization and this is what
Madison did he starts it with the
Establishment Clause and the Free
Exercise Clause two clauses
Establishment Clause is freedom from
religion now remember that the first
thing in the First Amendment is freedom
from religion it prevents people from
shoving their religion down your throat
secondly free exercise of religion the
ability to exercise your religion free
from government compulsion now to put
the two of them together and what
Madison was working on was conscious
freedom of conscience he wanted a third
clause that would protect secular
conscience he couldn't get it through
the Senate in 1789 but the Supreme Court
has put it back in through a kind of
word magic so when we look at the first
two clauses now the Establishment Clause
in the Free Exercise Clause we have
freedom of conscience and if you want a
democracy that's where a democracy has
to start it starts in the free thought
of a free citizen now once that thought
generates an idea the next thing you
need in a democracy is the ability to
articulate the idea so it's no
coincidence that the free speech Clause
is third it comes after the to
conscience clauses so the once you
enunciate an idea in your free
conscience the free speech Clause allows
you to
peak but speaking is not enough in a
democracy
I hope I'm gonna reach more people on
this program then I will be able to
speak to personally in my whole life
so that Madison realized that you need a
fourth clause and the fourth clause is a
free press clause to be able to magnify
your speech amplify it and allow it to
reach a mass audience and then he said
hey after it reaches the mass audience
what's the next thing that democracy
needs well the next thing that democracy
needs is the right to free collective
action once you have a freely expressed
idea that has been spoken under the
speech clause disseminated to a mass
audience under the press Clause the next
thing is to organize to organize around
it and that's what freedom of assembly
is freedom of assembly is the freedom to
take collective action in support of a
democratic idea and it couldn't come
anywhere else couldn't come before
speech it couldn't come before press
because you can't have a collective
action until you have mass dissemination
of the idea and then finally after mass
dissemination of the idea in the
collective action clause you then have
the petition clause which is the right
to take that idea and bring it to the
other to the authorities to the
legislature to the president and require
them to act on it one way or the other
so when you think about it the first
amendment is a story of the life cycle
of a democratic idea beginning in the
free conscience of a free citizen freely
articulated disseminated in a mass basis
organized around through assembly and
finally presented to the government for
petition and and every single word is
exactly where it should be and if only
we would read it as this collect has
this wonderful poem to democracy there's
no way that we could read the First
Amendment the way the Supreme Court does
today to essentially let the super-rich
control democracy to what the support
the Supreme Court has done is torn the
free speech Clause out of the heart of
the First Amendment itself and used it
as a mechanism to say money equals
speech
therefore any amount of spending is
protected by the First Amendment even if
it completely undercuts the ability to
have a fair robust egalitarian democracy
and so what the court has done is it's
turned of the First Amendment from being
democracy's best friend which is what
Madison was trying to create and is
turned it into a bad parent it's turned
it into a the free speech clause
police's democracy it disciplines
democracy it prevents democracy from
working even when the law itself is
designed to allow democracy to work and
my hope is that if people take a look at
my book if they're persuaded that there
is a story a wonderful poem in that 45
words that they will realize that you
have to construe the amendment as
democracy's enabling force the thing
that makes democracy work and not as
some sort of device that makes it harder
for democracy to work and I think one of
the the ways in which calling it a
device used sometimes for personal or
political gain is the way that free
speech and the First Amendment have been
misused colloquially in recent history
I'll give you a couple of examples that
really represent this misuse or
misunderstanding one is there was this
radio host dr. Laura Wright and she used
the n-word 11 times on the radio while
working for a private employer her
audience was offended she did not renew
her contract and said she had to go
elsewhere to regain her free speech
First Amendment rights this to me
epitomizes such a fundamental
misunderstanding of what we're talking
about it doesn't involve the government
first of all and number two correct me
if I'm wrong freedom of speech
even when we talk about the government
as the sort of arbiter of whether you
have that freedom or not freedom of
speech does not guarantee immunity from
the consequences of that speech based on
my reading you tell me if you disagree
oh sure of course David that's right I
mean what the current Supreme Court has
done and what a lot of people do is they
take is they completely ignore the fact
that there are all forty-five words in
there
they take the 10 words of the free
speech clause which says Congress shall
make no law abridging the freedom of
speech so they then take the freedom of
out because after all the freedom of
doesn't have any literal meaning what is
the freedom of me and it means what we
say it means it's a man-made concept and
somebody has to decide it so they throw
that away because that did you a
headache it's too hard to think about
and then what they wind up doing is
saying what the what the free speech
Clause says is Congress shall make no
law abridging speech and then you get a
radio host like that who says well it
says Congress shall make no law
abridging speech somebody abridged my
speech therefore something terrible
happened but that's not what the free
speech Clause says first of all it says
the freedom of speech which means that
you don't have a right to threaten
people you don't have a right to extort
money you don't have a right to engage
in false advertising the there are
limits because it was not part of the
freedom of speech and then they ignore
the fact that hearers have rights too
the reason we protect free speech is
because of the dignity of the individual
we think that everybody's dignity means
that they should be able to express
themselves and I agree with that and I
didn't a service league legal director
of the ACLU because I didn't believe in
the dignity of everyone to express
themselves but I think hearers have
dignity to UM and targets the people
that the speech is about they have
dignity also well along along those
lines I'm curious what you would think
of with all the discussion now of
so-called religious freedom bills what
happens when you have conflicting
religious freedom for example if you
have Christians refusing to serve
Muslims because the Christian believes
that his religious freedom allows him to
turn away whoever has religious beliefs
they disagree with but the Muslim also
may be discriminated against based on
their religious beliefs what are the
limits of that well David that's an
important perception because this isn't
no I remember when I was a young civil
rights lawyer working in the south and
the 60s um one of the arguments that the
segregationist made was that
they had a religious right to refuse
service to blacks and that they and that
it was therefore a violation of their
religious rights to say that blacks had
a right to come into the store or to the
amusement park or to rent from a
landlord and we overrode that we said
that's ridiculous yeah you're not yet
nobody has a First Amendment right to
treat someone else unequally because um
the fact is your freedom of religion
stops at the point that you use your
religion to shift real costs to a third
person and that's because the
Establishment Clause is there the the
reason the First Amendment starts with
the Establishment Clause is that Madison
realized that there should be freedom
from religion you cannot ask the
government to take your religious
beliefs and pound them into somebody
else um so that you cannot ask the
government to say that you have a right
to say that you won't serve gays or that
you won't serve blacks so that you won't
serve Muslims or that you won't serve
Jews if you open up a place of public
accommodations and there's a law that
says you have to serve everybody equally
there's no religious defense to that law
because the moment there is a religious
defense to that law what you wind up
with is saying that you can ask the
government to impose a defense on a
third person and make that third person
bear the costs of your religious belief
the Free Exercise Clause is all about
enjoying the free exercise of religion
when it doesn't shift across to anyone
else when you bear the costs yourself
but you don't have a right under the
First Amendment to run around and use
the religion clauses as a club to beat
someone else and say I can make you
endure the costs of my religious freedom
well it's very clear particularly given
what is going on in the last few weeks
very important discussion there's so
much more to talk about and we will have
to do it next time we have you on we've
been speaking with Burton newborn I'll
remind you the book is Madison's music
on reading the First Amendment
could not recommend it more highly so
relevant today thanks so much for being
on with them thank you David and enjoy
the David Pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
we've been following what I have
generally characterized as a definitive
and decided war on Free Press by the
Trump administration and this has
multiple components and none of these
should come as a surprise to you because
I've been talking about these over time
the idea of the media as the enemy of
the American people that having trouble
today I can't I can't imagine why
journalism licenses being required to
practice media libel lawsuits made
easier we had of course countless tweets
from Donald Trump about this including
the following tweet the fake news media
failing New York Times NBC News ABC CBS
CNN is not my enemy it is the enemy of
the American people and last week during
a Jim Acosta and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
it's being described as an exchange I
call it more of a kerfuffle I think
maybe high-rate a tirade of sorts the
White House refused to deny that the
press was the enemy of the American
people and in fact I would argue Sarah
Huckabee Sanders sort of confirmed it by
saying Trump has already told us what
his position is on that and I speak on
the behalf of the President and we now
have a new poll to sort of add to our
fleshing out of whether this is a
strategy that's working 43 percent not
4.3 percent not 14.3% not twenty four
point three percent forty three percent
nearly half of Republicans believe that
Donald Trump should be able to
unilaterally just say this media outlet
it's over whatever the Year fired
equivalent is that you would say to a
media outlet when they're going away 48%
of Republicans in the same poll agree
that the media is the enemy of the
American people and this is where you
have to understand the I don't want to
call it brilliance but the power of
these campaigns by Trump where even
without saying straight up all media is
the enemy of the American people or
media in principle are the enemies of
the American people half of Republicans
are believing it and dump Trump didn't
even have to say it in as explicit terms
as he could have now in comparison 12%
of Democrats and 21% of in depend
agree about President Trump closing down
media outlets those numbers are still
higher than I would like to see right
like the number should be if anyone who
understands America is asked should the
president be able to say you are off the
air the answer should always be no we
have systems in place we have limits as
to what can legally be reported if your
FCC bound because of your broadcast
platforms there are rules governing the
answer should never be yes the president
should get to say you're off the air
whether it's 12% for Dems 21 for
independents or 43 for Republicans it's
all horrible yeah I'd like to see it at
0% of course we'll never get that maybe
just a few percentage points I would
take because this is the American public
after all very very well you it's hard
to get zero percent of Americans
agreeing on anything right let me put a
different way it's hard to get a hundred
percent of Americans agreeing on
anything
overall 57 percent of respondents
believe that media is necessary to keep
the Trump administration honest I would
agree with that
13% of Americans agreed that President
Trump should close down mainstream news
outlets like CNN The Washington Post in
the New York Times what I go to is
number one there's a partisan element
right like if a Democrat were president
right now you would probably see
Democrats to a slightly higher degree
saying Obama should get to close down
whatever and Republicans lower but it's
not just hypocrisy there is no question
that the so-called constitutional
conservatives who claim to be all about
the Bill of Rights and separation of
powers and checks and balances and all
this stuff they seemed completely
unconcerned with the fact that there is
nothing in the First Amendment which
would allow for a president to just say
this media outlet doesn't get to
continue or that media outlet doesn't
get to continue and part of what has
been going on that predates the Trump
administration that fuels this is a
distrust of media in general right in
addition to the likely partisan divide
that there is in general you have a high
distrust of media and I often have asked
about this right people will say to me
David if
you're so often critical of media
outlets how are you now worried about
the fact that Trump is criticizing media
what you have to understand is there's a
difference between identifying a
particular media outlet that's doing bad
reporting and criticizing them that's
one thing versus me saying the president
should get to pick which media outlets
exist these are completely unrelated
problems that we're dealing with and
unfortunately a lot of people are going
in the wrong direction on this
seventy-two percent of respondents
believe it should be easier to sue
reporters willingly publishing false
information remember the key word is
easier there's already laws that prevent
reporters or punish reporters from
punish a Ephrem publishing willingly
false information and it's working and
it's being reflected by Trump's own
followers here's one example where CNN's
reporter Jim Acosta was just yelled at
and Badger during a Trump rally in
Florida recently
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so there are a number of disturbing
angles to this generally number one the
authoritarian tendencies shutting down
media lack of press freedom right we see
this in places like Venezuela we've seen
it in China North Korea Turkey doesn't
like the internet we heard from
president air21 that he's increasingly
against the internet every day when you
see leaders one thing to have this level
of control that is an authoritarian
tendency and worse when you've got half
of one party saying you want them to
have that control that is really really
scary beyond that I already mentioned
there's the constitutional angle here
what exceptions are there to freedom of
the press that would allow a president
to close down a media outlet but in the
end it's just more hypocrisy than it is
anything else the principles don't
matter
there is a contingent out there and it
is where the Alex Jones story brought a
lot of them out right when it's Alex
Jones being taken off of youtube youtube
is unjustifiably censoring Alex Jones
which isn't the government by the way
but then all of a sudden Republicans are
asked would you want the president
meaning the government to just be able
to select media outlets to shut down and
half of them say yes
it doesn't Square there is no way where
both of those views can be held
simultaneously without huge cognitive
dissonance I think we all see what Trump
is doing here I don't think he would
actively pursue shutting down media
outlets and he wouldn't say anything to
that effect but he calls the media faked
news and he builds this distrust among
his supporters so that they then fill in
the blanks and reason that it's
important for us to shut down these
outlets Trump's goal is to not have to
shut down the media outlets to make them
completely uneffective if you turn
public opinion against them enough if
you frame them as the enemies of the
American people and simultaneously
spread so much diss and misinformation
that people don't know what to believe
you won't need to shut down any of the
media outlets because they won't be
functioning as intended to begin with
last question today hey David in your TJ
Kirk amazing atheist interview he talked
about considering social media as if it
is a government entity
that cannot restrict speech unless it is
illegal it wasn't clear if you supported
it you don't actually think the
government should force private
companies to publish content they don't
want to do you know I don't so my view
is that if you want to argue that
certain social media platforms have
become so ubiquitous that they should be
treated as though they are sort of
governmental in how speech laws should
apply to them then you need to actually
legislate that there is legal
infrastructure dating back to the mid
sixties that would determine when a
platform has reached that status I don't
believe that that's something that
should be done I'm against that as the
quote solution to the problem of speech
on social networks and media platforms
but what I what I do think is that if
you are someone who supports that you
need to establish that legally through
the legal infrastructure that exists
that's not my solution that's not what I
want done but if you are someone who
wants that done then we know exactly
what needs to happen legally I don't
think that that's the solution I am okay
I think that it's perfectly reasonable
you know there's this movement now to
say how can you say you're for Business
Regulation but all of a sudden now you
think Facebook should be able to do
whatever they want if their speech they
don't like like Alex Jones speech on the
other side there's those on the Left who
look at the right and they say how can
you say you are for businesses being
able to do whatever they want if now
you're saying Facebook should be forced
to publish Alex Jones's content there
these are two different issues right
we're talking about what is legal under
the what decisions are legal for
businesses to make and then what
decisions are illegal for businesses to
make like saying we are not going to
allow black customers or Jewish
customers that would be an illegal
decision do I think that it's a great
thing for platforms to be banning lots
of content wholesale no I don't think
it's a great thing big picture did Alex
Jones clearly violate the Terms of
Service of the platforms from which he
got banned absolutely the problem is the
selective enforcement because there are
way smaller content creators than Alex
Jones who do the exact same stuff and
they've not been banned arguably because
they're completely under the radar and
that's the concern I have none of these
companies did anything illegal and all
of these companies are more than
entitled more than entitled to have
Terms of Service and to enforce them if
you don't believe that then you have to
establish legally that they should be
regulated in terms of speech the way the
government is regulated I don't think
that's the solution send me your
thoughts if you disagree we have a
fantastic bonus show today we will talk
about the economy we will talk about
Pluto we will also talk about the most
and least valuable college degrees all
of that and more on today's bonus show
look forward to speaking to you back
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you